and I think I have a beautiful moment
for you right
now if we can welcome to the floor
everybody the
president of your Miami Heat Pat Riley
with a very special note for Dwayne
Wayne
Jack what is this what that look like
bam that look like bam coach like a
glorious Bobblehead Is that bam look
like bam that's a
bobblehead we got a bobblehead right
here
but you know what else are we going to
hang from the rafters uh know we hung a
couple of Championship banners and you
know Atlantic Coast Conference banners
and then we h a gold medal Banner then
we retired your your old butt we hung it
from the rafters in the Hall of Fame we
put up there today so what else we going
to hang from the banner or from the
rafters uh I think we're going to put a
bobble head like out there next year
will be a statue 8 ft
tall 8T
tall we wanted to make sure it was
bigger than Shaquille
O'Neal it'll be the first statue
ever that they'll be here on bis game
Boulevard Dwayne and it is forever for
the greatest player in the history of
this game man you know I love
you next year everybody right here we'll
be a
statue and I want to thank the arrison
family they're the ones that came up
with the idea so it's going to be great
good luck to you my man and here you get
to get the Bible head for a while okay
just play with it you take care Pat
thank you very much what does it mean to
you that when people go on the Google
Earth and pull up 601 bis game
Boulevard a monument erected forever in
your honor will be
there I'm not I'm not really a person
who get lost for words
I got too many words
actually
um I didn't dream of this though and
so man I'm just I'm just I'm just so
grateful I'm very grateful uh thank to
Arison family thank to Riley family um
thank the city and the State of Florida
and Miami just fall in love and I can't
wait for families to be able to
experience what that's going to be like
from all around the world um to come and
have a moment of of the culture that
will be out front so I can't wait till
that day man so I'm excited can't wait
to have you back for another gathering
with all your family and friends ladies
and gentlemen the
2023 nay Smith Memorial Basketball Hall
of Famer the greatest player in the
history of the heat Dwayne way way
County I love
you